well distance learning is extra
challenging for students who live in
underserved communities
discovery children's museum is trying to
change that they opened a free study
hall so that kids don't go through
distance learning alone
our hector mejia is live this morning
with more on that program hey hector
hey there alex good morning the bell
here rings after 8 30 this morning and
the museum is essentially now school for
dozens of kids in the valley so it's a
really cool idea
joining us live we have amira abu dhala
to explain everything and
i mean don't you wish you went to a
museum and your classroom was inside a
museum when you grew up
definitely i think the museum is a great
resource for anyone and informal play is
a great way to learn and supplement
their learning at school
and you were telling me earlier that
some of these students had never stepped
into this museum before
until now exactly a lot of them are
exploring it for the very first time
and they're very excited to be here and
have a new opportunity to explore a
place they've never been before
and we're talking about students who
were probably just stuck at home
and now how are you guys helping them
out they need to be part of specific
schools so for those parents wondering
how they can join can you tell us all
about that yes so we serve uh grades one
through five they have to be part of a
reinvent school but if they reach out to
their counselor
principal or teacher they'll give you
more information about our study hall
program
gotta ask how do you keep students safe
right now you guys have a
different safety measures in place for
sure we have a very spacious classroom
and we limit the capacity to 10 in each
classroom
and then we also make sure that each uh
student is wearing a mask at all times
and of course we sanitize
and wash our hands a lot to prevent
anything
100 times a day 100 times a day for sure
so tell us you know i think it's uh the
limit is 50 students at a time
yes exactly so we have 50 students and
then in each classroom there's 10
students per grade
got you anything else you want to tell
us about the uh
the uh the classroom size in there um
the classroom is pretty spacious uh we
have a lot of social
um interactions with the kids especially
since
you know they're going out to a more
social place during this time it's a
really neat idea and they get to spend
recess inside the museum so they really
get to explore a lot thank you very much
for having us
we have all of this information already
posted on our website so if you want to
check it out
you can just head over to
eightnewsnow.com and find all of the
details
right now reporting live hector mejia
eight news now and alex from all of the
children here
happy birthday thank you hector bring
back that picture
i want to put it on my desk thank you
hector okay
john overdue